Traductor: Denise RQ
Revisor: Sebastian Betti
Cada día nos enfrentamos
a un mar de decisiones.
Algunas son pequeñas y sin importancia,
pero otras tienen un mayor
impacto en nuestras vidas.
Por ejemplo, ¿a qué político votar?
¿Debo probar lo último en dietas?
¿O enviar un correo electrónico
me hará millonario?
Nos bombardean con tantas decisiones
que es imposible decantarse por
la decisión correcta cada vez.
Pero hay muchas maneras de
mejorar nuestras posibilidades,
y una técnica particularmente
eficaz es el pensamiento crítico.
Esta es una manera de
acercarse a una pregunta
que nos permite deconstruir
cuidadosamente una situación,
revelar sus problemas ocultos,
como los prejuicios y la manipulación
y tomar la mejor decisión.
Si la parte crítica suena algo negativo
es porque en cierto modo lo es.
En lugar de elegir un respuesta
porque parece y suena bien,
una persona que usa pensamiento crítico
sopesa las alternativas disponibles
y las examina con escepticismo.
Con la ayuda de las herramientas
que están a su disposición
dejará de lado todo salvo
la información más útil y fiable.
Hay muchas maneras diferentes
de acercarse al pensamiento crítico,
y aquí se describe un proceso en 5 pasos
que puede ayudarte
a solucionar cualquier problema.
Primer paso: formula tu pregunta.
En otras palabras:
debes saber qué buscas.
Esto no siempre es
tan sencillo como parece.
Por ejemplo, si te decides
a probar lo último en dietas,
otros factores pueden complicar
tu motivación para hacerlo
como la afirmación de que se pueden
ver resultados en solo dos semanas.
Pero si adoptas tu enfoque
con una visión clara de lo que
tratas de lograr con la dieta,
sea bajar de peso, una alimentación
más sana, o una recarga de energía,
esto te ayudará a navegar a través de
esta información de manera crítica,
encontrar lo que estás buscando
y decidir si este nuevo capricho
realmente se adapta a tus necesidades.
Segundo paso: recopila tu información.
Hay muchos datos
así que tener una idea clara
te ayudará a determinar lo relevante.
Si estás tratando de decidirte sobre
una dieta para mejorar tu alimentación
a lo mejor pides
el consejo de los expertos,
o buscas los testimonios
de otras personas.
La recopilación de información
te ayuda sopesar diferentes opciones,
lo que te lleva más cerca de la decisión
que te ayuda alcanzar tu meta.
Tercer paso: pon en práctica
la información,
algo que se logra haciendo
preguntas críticas.
Frente a una decisión, pregúntate:
"¿Qué conceptos funcionan en este caso?"
"¿Qué suposiciones existen?"
"¿Es mi interpretación de la información
válida lógicamente?"
Por ejemplo, en un correo electrónico
que te promete millones,
debes tener en cuenta que factores
están en juego en esta situación".
"¿Supongo que el remitente
está diciendo la verdad?"
"Basándome en la evidencia, ¿es lógico
suponer que voy a ganar dinero?"
Cuatro paso: tener en
cuenta las consecuencias.
Imagina que hay elecciones,
y te has decidido por un candidato
político con base en su promesa
de bajar los precios de la gasolina.
A primera vista, esto suena muy bien.
¿Pero qué pasa con los efectos sobre
el medioambiente a largo plazo?
Si el consumo de gasolina
no baja debido a su precio
esto también podría causar un enorme
aumento en la contaminación del aire,
una consecuencia no deseada
que es importante considerar.
Quinto paso: considera
otros puntos de vista.
Pregúntate por qué tantas
personas se sienten atraídas
por la política del candidato
político de la oposición.
Incluso si no estás de acuerdo con
nada de lo que dice ese candidato,
considerar todos los puntos
de vista podría aclarar
por qué algunas políticas que no parecen
válidas sí lo son para los demás.
Esto te permitirá considerar
otras alternativas,
evaluar tus propias decisiones
y en última instancia te ayudará a tomar
más decisiones bien fundamentadas.
Este proceso en 5 pasos
es solo una herramienta,
y ciertamente no erradicará las
decisiones difíciles de nuestras vidas.
Pero puede ayudarnos a aumentar
el número de decisiones
positivas que tomamos.
El pensamiento crítico nos puede
brindar las herramientas necesarias
para enfrentarnos a un mar de decisiones
y encontrar lo que estamos buscando.
Y si muchos pensamos críticamente
eso hará del mundo
un lugar más razonable.